i do wonder i'm like what causes like
what happens in your
are you born wanting to do extremes like
explore caves or go to extreme heights
is that like something you're born with
or is that something you like
that has to be something you're born
with or is that something that like over
your life something happens when you're
a kid and it's just
you know no because like i feel that you
know from a young age there's always
like the kids
who are you know going to be like yeah
i'm going to climb this really tall tree
watch i was like that as a kid i would
climb anything and then
i don't know what i think maybe the
first time you you fall over badly and
you're like
[ __ ] this [ __ ] actually hurts if you
fall i think it's the difference i think
it's the difference between
when you fall off that tree and you hurt
yourself it's the difference between
[ __ ] i'm never doing that again yeah
well [ __ ] that was worth it
yeah can you pinpoint the moment at any
point in your life where you've like
you know exactly where your fear came
from for something i mean
you'll be right be my bee one yeah i i i
i still have that memory to this day
yeah for me well i have a
i'm afraid of heights but like not too
bad like it depends
but you could be i think like there's an
experiment on kids right
some kids are born like people are born
with naturally a fear of heights yeah
right right but i feel that
my fear of heights came from the fact
that at my parents place we have this
kind of spiral staircase that goes down
before and i fell down that oh no yeah
and
luckily i didn't like break any bones or
like hurt myself that badly but i hit
like
i think i was only maybe like two or
three years old when i did and it's the
earliest memory i have yeah
of me just falling down and i'm pretty
sure that caused
a slight maybe like a fear of hiding
something
doesn't it scare you that like little
things that happened to you as a kid
can just like [ __ ] you up yeah it makes
me scared to have kids i'm like whoa
what if i like accidentally give him
like too much broccoli and he won't have
chicken and broccoli ever again man like
i traumatized him right how do i know
it's gonna traumatize the kids
that's the first thing you come with i
don't know why i could be traumatized
with chicken and
if my kid right doesn't eat the [ __ ]
cross i'm gonna be
sitting there on the table with like the
bottle of whiskey being like where are
they where did it all go
where's the [ __ ] button i used to be
really claustrophobic i don't really get
it anymore
but i used to be really much the kid i
know exactly why and it took me like
years to realize like oh that probably
was traumatizing
um so one time uh my our parents were
out and it was me and my brothers
messing around and we thought
bro that's just a suitcase we can do so
much fun stuff with a suitcase
for some reason so for some reason i
think me and my brothers decide we're
going to take turns
locking on each other in the suitcase
right
right so so uh i don't know why we
decided to do this again we were like
four or five yeah so i i i got locked in
the suitcase bear in mind
for some reason i thought i should eat
my uh cocoa puffs in the suitcase
sorry i i was in my suitcase basically i
was in the suitcase just eating cocoa
puffs right now
what was the point of this what would
you get out i legitimately don't know
why we did this i just have this memory
and then they started a kid thing to do
and then my older brother thought it'd
be funny to start flipping the suitcase
with cocoa puffs and then that was where
i drew the line i was like get me out
get me out of here that he wouldn't let
me out for like 10 minutes and i was
like
i feel as well i feel as well with that
kind of like childhood trauma it really
depends on like what your siblings did
to you
yeah yeah yeah i mean i'm very glad that
i had siblings because i feel like
man i don't know i i learned a lot of
valuable lessons i think it's because me
and my sister we kind of
like think the same way in a lot of
things so like we wouldn't do something
to the other person that we would hate
to do
this is if you have only child when you
have like three brothers like i said man
it's like [ __ ] wrestlemania yeah yeah
it's like
like so we would like genuinely have
like full fist fights yeah we'd like
punch each other in the face
yeah i hear about this with like sydney
and russell had a similar thing where
like apparently they would just like
punch the [ __ ] out of each other and
that's just like sibling love i guess
but it was like if if like if we it
stuff got really
like bad like we had a really bad
argument like we put into fighting